hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to space pirate trainer now
I was just playing this game and it went
a little wrong ah
oh [ __ ] there's a ceiling there I need
to be more careful from my physical
space because reality is not as cool as
virtual reality but either way welcome
to this game it is freaking amazing so
da that's so cool oh look at that
Oh oh that's so cool
alright so here's the deal this game is
freakin awesome I just got done playing
Brookhaven experiment and that game was
amazing I want to play that again on my
own just cuz it was so fun this one
might be just as fun because it's the
same concept but you're training to be a
space pirate oh oh look at that
duel death laser ah sucka laser sucka
laser oh so cool oh so cool and the
music's not bad either
and it's so long as I'm not jumping
around like a goddamn fool and trying to
get melted so long as I'm not jumping
around like a fool and trying to be an
idiot I should be okay and be capable of
every rule would be weird you go why
whoa whoa whoa Donn's you [ __ ] that's
you Wow hey you want to fight a fight
bruh ain't gonna happen see the guns got
a lot of different things that I could
do so I can mix them up between the two
but I like the double laser it's just
fancy and free where do you think you're
going great hey you're going I mean I
get tangled up whoa
God is yeah I'm like in the matrix I'm
like the neo at least it's giving me a
good boundary box of where I can go woo
woo
okay.come cross the fringe whoa hey whoa
hey whoa whoa whoa
see I couldn't use a shield you do have
a shield as well like this so this can
block bullets but I'm gonna dodge him
cuz I'm freakin awesome and I really
want to get my workout in today
apparently nope you can also like if
they start firing you didn't like just
tap them oh oh oh whoo whoo whoo oh whoa
whoa ah that sat in my face sealed out
of this
I need a shield okay we're gonna go full
auto Oh whoo goodbye
oh so it's so cool guys it's so cool oh
whoa whoa
ha ha ha ha ha Oh Oh Danny they got me
oh they got me I'm win oh it's okay yes
yeah yeah bleh ah
oh god this may be a problem might be a
problem might be a problem
whoo might be a problem might be a
problem okay not a problem
whoa whoa [ __ ] you whoa whoa oh yes oh
yes oh sorry I put on earbuds so that I
wouldn't have to scream all the time I'm
just a little excited about me
whoa-ho-ho
how about you [ __ ] off whoa ha goddamn
who's hitting me
ah what this seems like death oh I
wasn't paying attention
Oh oh man oh I almost be my other high
score of course I went with shield
before last time but I think I just
pulled on my head
I think double gun is the way to go
because me likey dodging Bam Bam oh so
satisfying oh it's so satisfying
you can technically aim through DS but
then you can only look down one at a
time you're better off just finding the
center point and then shooting with
reckless abandon you want to come to me
I'm gonna have my old favorite was these
because they're basically just just off
super lasers the long as you got your
aim right whoa whoa whoa whoa well drew
whoa ah goddamnit I don't have my am
right whoa whoa whoa stop it oh god damn
it
okay so I got to find the right weapon
because otherwise I'm just gonna be I'm
gonna be clubber knock
okay okay this is gonna be the one this
is the one this is the one I ain't
fooling around this time I'm all make
sense I'm ready to go I'm in the best
shape of my life
whoa what that didn't even give me
swallow what the hell is that talking
about okay doing okay doing good doing
good I knew we would doing good bring it
on bring it on bring it on whoa whoa
well what do you do whoa whoa jeezum x'
oh whoa Nelly
whoa Nelly aah I'm on the road I
shouldn't be on the ground
whoa whoa whoa whoa holy crap
okay it's really giving I'm really
giving it my all guys I'm giving all on
the ground leaving it all on the table
whoa Oh aah
can I shoot them their lasers out of
midair I think that's my did okay we're
going to lasers again Oh falling leaves
this foggy lasers everywhere if it has
the added bonus of preventing them from
hitting me cuz it delays better and I'm
out of breath because god damn it I
haven't moved as much since oh I don't
know I can't even come up with something
clever ah I give me batteries back uh uh
lasers well [ __ ] look we're doing that
put it out
hello under what scooter where can
someone find my back what's up what's up
back oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you okay
what who goddamnit ah I'm giving to my
all guys I can beat my other high-score
I can beat I don't need a shield I just
got to focus one at a time and not lose
them there's a radar there that can show
me where they are
I am so sweaty right now but it's all
for the better it's all for good it's
all for greatness
what I have greatness is all that I know
I am the best and I will only be the
best if you guys believe in me okay so I
can alternate one gun than the other if
I want to let one recharge BAM okay
clear them out good I'm getting better
with these lasers my score is way higher
than it was last time are you going you
know I said nope yeah I don't even have
to dodge like a maniac hello
I do I do after dusk like a maniac yeah
I can clear their bullets either way
he's still alive down there there we go
okay no you did not okay just like that
my score already is beating the high
score I'm already the king oh god here
they come
that's a lot of you that's a lot of you
but I'm ready no no no no no no whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
okay the implementation of like
physically dodging is so amazing like I
mean I'm all for hyperbole most of the
time but to be honest this is literally
like this changes everything I'm
physically here and it's utilizing that
aspect of what I do like it's utilizing
the physicality of it I'm literally here
I'm moving it's bonkers got them got
them yeah okay I'm getting better
hand-eye coordination so that I can
actually move this appropriately where I
need to go where I need to go glowy ones
are the ones that are gonna shoot on you
next you got a watch for those bastards
oh that's scary that's scary that's
super scary whoa whoa clucks okay I
don't know where they are
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh [ __ ] whoa
whoa ha ha no you don't oh it's not
ready for that
I was actually legitimately scary whoo
whoo yes yes
m-mother humper oh [ __ ]
aah oh man
murk with the high score at least for
here
oh man doing that without a shield is so
much harder but it is so much more fun
let me just put my double shields on the
ground here take this off and thank you
everybody so much for watching this is
so fun I cannot describe how cool but
how physically demanding but that's good
I am dripping with sweat but I haven't
had that much fun in so long it's so
cool so thank you everybody so much for
watching there's so many more cool
virtual reality stuff coming in the
future I really hope you guys enjoy
watching this thanks again for taking
the time and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
honey is that you darling dear oh my
love
we just go explore the house and see if
we break it yeah I guess